[Music]
we are sharing more
never before seen moments from oprah's
interview with prince harry and his wife
megan back in january 2020
the couple announced plans to step back
as senior members of the royal family
in this exclusive never-before-seen clip
harry and megan tell oprah
they were then invited to spend time
with his grandmother the queen
but the plans changed that announcement
that we put out on the 8th of january in
2020
that was the contents of that was put
into a letter
to the institution to my father which
was then shared at the end of december
while we were in canada
and to then get back on the sixth
after my grandmother had said the moment
you land come up to
when i asked we could go don't come up
to sandringham we'd love to have a have
a chat come for team
why don't you stay for dinner because
it's gonna be a long drive and you're
gonna be exhausted
i love that yeah the moment we landed in
the uk i got a message from my private
secretary fiona at the time
uh private secretary is sort of like a
ceo okay
cutting and pasting a message from the
queen's private secretary basically
saying
please pass on to the duke and duchess
of sussex that
he cannot come to norfolk the queen is
busy she's busy all week
after she just invited you yeah just
invite me the queen's busy she's busy
all week
do not come up here okay so i rang her
from frogmore
um that night and said i was thinking
about coming anyway
but i hear you're now busy and and she
said yes there's something in my diary
that i didn't know
that i had and i said well what about
the rest of the week she goes well
that's busy now as well
okay i didn't want to push because i
kind of knew what was going on
and and then later that night
but doesn't the queen get to do i mean
doesn't the queen get to do what the
queen wants to do
no when you're head of the firm there is
people around you that give you advice
okay and what has also made me really
sad is some of that advice has been
really bad
wow yeah that was tough you know it's
the type of thing when someone says i'm
busy and oh by the way i'm busy all week
that's a big sign well but when it's
your mother that's
yeah when it when it's your grandmother
that's tough